le béton est le matériau le plus utilisé
sur terre sa production un poids
environnemental énorme parce qu'elle
génère d'importantes émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais il existe une
solution et a été développée ici
c'est un pont pour le moins modeste
qu'on traverse sans trop s'en rendre
compte
pourtant il s'agit d'une première
mondiale
il est fait d'un béton plus vert grâce
en ciment dopé à la goutte de vin
[Musique]
septembre 2020 sur l'île des soeurs à
montréal c'est l'habituel va et vient
des camions malaxeurs
on donne naissance au premier de deux
jumeaux les ponts darwin comme
d'habitude chaque livraison de béton et
testés
et acceptés uniquement si elle répond
aux critères pour comprendre la suite il
faut bien distinguer le béton du ciment
le béton
c'est un mélange de sable et gravier et
le ciment c'est la colle qui fait tenir
tout ça ensemble
c'est un des ingrédients du béton la
recette a fait ses preuves mais hélène
faiblesse sur le plan de l'environnement
les bétons modernes sont d'excellente
qualité il n'y a pas de problème là
c'est surtout au niveau de la
fabrication du ciment qui est très
énergivore
la production du ciment utilisé dans le
béton génère des gaz à effet de serre et
deux fois plutôt qu'une
d'abord parce que le ciment est fabriqué
à très haute température ce qui implique
souvent des énergies fossiles comme le
charbon et le pétrole mais aussi parce
que cette chaleur sarah brisé du
calcaire caco3 en deux moitiés du ca au
qui va dans le ciment et du co2 qui va
dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
au total l'industrie du ciment émet
autant de gaz à effet de serre que celle
du plastique ou de l'aviation
[Musique]
d'où l'intérêt d'un projet pilote comme
celui des ponts darwin la ville de
montréal cherche à réduire l'impact
environnemental du béton en utilisant
moins de six mois ce qu'on vient faire
nous dans notre projet c'est qu'on va
remplacer 10% delà du ciment par la
poudre de verre et ça c'est le résultat
du travail d'une vie celle d'un risk it
and yet amour il ya très longtemps j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur les six morts
dans une autre vie j'ai même été
cimentier avant de devenir professeur
et puis a certes il ya très longtemps
j'ai compris que le ciment à certains
moments il faut trouver à le remplacer
par d'autres ce qu'on appelle des ajouts
six volontaires
[Musique]
des ajouts cimentaire il en existe déjà
qui viennent d'ailleurs depuis 15 ans
avec son équipe de l'université de
sherbrooke
il mise sur un produit local le vert
mélanger celui des bouteilles qu'on
attende mal à recycler oui ça c'est du
vers la cdu verts mix donc ça c'est du
vert bois y est finement tu es très très
fins et de l'ordre de quelques microns
un peu plus fin que le ciment portland
mais quand on le bras finement bse le
sait la couleur naturelle de la silice
qui prend le dessus et donc c'est tout
blanc
la ressemblance n'est pas seulement
visuel entre le ciment et la poudre de
vannes pour fabriquer du verre on
chauffe de la silice à très haute
température
la chaleur des formes les cristaux
certains ces tirs
d'autres se comprime ses déformations
emmagasinent de l'énergie car la silice
veut retrouver sa forme originale elle
est prête à réagir
ce qui rend la côte de verre plus
écologique c'est qu'on rentabilise de
l'énergie qu'on a déjà investi pour
fabriquer le vert au lieu de dépenser
encore de l'énergie pour fabriquer du
nouveau ciment mais le ver ne peut pas
lui seul servir de colle au béton et lui
font un autre ingrédient lachaud qui
provient du ciment traditionnel pour le
béton du pont darwin on a opté pour une
colle qui contient principalement du
ciment portland qui réagit en premier et
qui permet aux 10% de pots de verre de
réagir ensuite
[Musique]
sur le chantier
l'équipe de l'université de sherbrooke
avait récolté des dizaines
d'échantillons de ce béton
on veut vérifier en laboratoire que
cette réaction en deux temps du ciment
puis de la pâte de verre a bien
fonctionné
le béton mais plusieurs mois à mûrir et
au fur et à mesure on vérifie que sa
résistance en compression augmente
les matériaux cimentaires comme la
poudre de verre y met un peu de temps à
démarrer
parce que donc la chaux on vient du
ciment d'abord pour que et commencent à
réagir donc à jeune âge ils ont quelques
difficultés à démarrer mais à long terme
il dépasse les résistances même du btan
témoin
on soumet aussi les échantillons à des
centaines de ces cubes de gel et de
dégel et c'est là que se révèle sa plus
grande qualité
ce qui est important c'est la durabilité
les résistance en compression pour
autant qu'on a atteint une certaine
marge de résistance après ça bah c'est
là dessus la durabilité qui est
importante et dans ce cas là la poudre
de verre bonifie énormément la
durabilité
le secret de sa durabilité
c'est l'étanchéité pour la mesurer aux
copains échantillons en tranches
elles seront ensuite gorgée d'eau est
placé entre deux liquides ton teint est
tout simplement de l'eau salée en
appliquant courant électrique
on force les particules de sel lésions à
migrer dans le béton - le béton est
poreux - lésions diffuse et mieux le
béton va résister aux agressions
le secret la de de la haute résistance
et de la haute performance c'est comment
est-ce que les particules soit vraiment
très très proche pour que y est pas de
porosité la plus grosse dimension va
jouer avec le dosage des granulats du
sable etc
mais il faut se rendre à l'évidence que
tout cet agencement que l'on voit à
l'échelle macro en réalité commence à
lâcher le micro et même nanométrique
c'est à ce niveau là de déchets qu'il
faut travailler pour améliorer bonifier
les btan de qualité les bétons de max
aujourd'hui certains de ces bétons sont
prêts à faire leurs preuves à servir
d'exemple en vue de projets encore plus
grand le but d'un projet pilote
d'un côté les chercheurs les universités
qui eux développent les matériaux mais
ça prend aussi des donneurs d'ordres
pour 30 des initiatives avoir l'audace
de les intégrer dans leurs
infrastructures et la tue areski tags et
amour est bien d'accord beaucoup
beaucoup de recherches se font eux
restent dans le laboratoire par manque
de moyens par manque de financement pour
se rendre du laboratoire au terrain ça
prend beaucoup beaucoup de bruit il ya
plusieurs pays qui sont jaloux de notre
cas collaboration avec l'industrie du
ciment et du béton mais avec aussi les
les propriétaires des ouvrages comme
c'est le cas de le remplacer 10% du
ciment par la boîte de verre ça peut
sembler très peu mais c'est 10% d'un
très gros problème du béton il y en a
partout
c'est le matériau le plus utilisé sur
terre une source majeure de gaz à effet
de serre
[Musique]
des pans darwin ce n'est que le début
d'une histoire qui aura en l'espère une
feuille des temps
[Musique]